[Music]  scandals series finale spoiler alert  David Rosen  dies as Olivia Pope may or may not have  become president who knows what's right  to Thursday's last episode of the ABC  drama did not disappoint Attorney  General David Rosen met his demise at  the hands of evil vice president Cyrus  Beene  while most of the original cast of  gladiators including at Kerry  Washington's Olivia Pope came out with  their white hats on right now it's time  to do something acting I'll cry later  and it seems Olivia may become president  in the future as her official portrait  was shown during the last scene of the  series in the National Gallery the whole  cast shared their reactions to the  finale on Jimmy Kimmel Live for about 10  or 15 seconds I think we all just sat  there yeah what had happened inside that  script did everyone use the tissues was  it three table read I think everyone was  Christ  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]